a Fox News Alert the Senate scrambling
as the clock ticks to avoid a partial
government shutdown at midnight tonight
a live look at the Senate floor where
Republicans are attempting to move
forward on a procedural vote but it's
unclear if they have the numbers to go
forward over at the White House the
president trying to place the potential
blame at Democrats feet it's really up
to the Democrats totally up to the
Democrats as to whether or not we have a
shutdown I hope we don't but we're
totally prepared for a very long
shutdown and this is our only chance
that we'll ever have in our opinion
because of the world and the way it
breaks out to get great border security
Senate Minority Leader Chuck Schumer
saying Trump would be at fault and
Democrats will not be budgeting on any
extra funding for the border wall
President Trump you will not get your
wall abandon your shutdown strategy
you're not getting the wall today next
week or on January 3rd when Democrats
take control of the house
Jessie everybody is kind of figure out
what's the endgame here how does the
president play out the strategy what do
you think I don't see the endgame wand I
really don't I mean if he has a bill
that gets to his desk and it doesn't
have wall funding he vetoes it or he
signs it and he says I tried but if he
vetoes it it just goes back and then
everything gets shut down and then maybe
it shut down for a week at most and then
the Democrats come in and take over and
they never send him anything with any
wall funding and you're back to square
one so I don't see the endgame I guess
maybe he's just trying to signal to the
people that he's gonna fight but he has
to find more creative ways in the budget
to build this wall the wall has to be
built and that's his signature promise
and he wasted the first time with it and
McConnell didn't deliver the first
opportunity and it's a shame but if they
get rid of the filibuster which they
won't you could get a wall you get a lot
of stuff the other side would get stuff
this side would get stuff but the way
that the system is designed in the
Senate
60 votes for these spending bills you're
never gonna get what you want and you're
just going to use the shutdown as
leverage time and time again and then we
have to talk about how boring it is so
Dana let's not talk about it's boring
because in fact this is a hot issue in
public opinion Quinnipiac has a poll out
54-43 no need for a while 62% of
Americans opposed to a shutdown but
among Republicans 59 to 33 say yes to
the wall right but also I would imagine
that 60% of Democrats say oh it's more
than I mean it's like it's the same so
this it's quite partisan I thought that
the language that Ted Cruz used earlier
today was interesting I think you'll
hear more that coming from Republicans
that the Democrats are extreme and
they're partisan and that the president
is the one who is middle-of-the-road on
this and commonsensical some of them
pointing back to February they'll
remember when the President had the
cameras in and it was in the Cabinet
Room it was that most amazing meeting
that anyone ever seen that deal at the
time would have given like 25 billion
dollars plus it had the daca fix so it's
like you keep going back like gosh maybe
that was the deal that they should have
had and taken back then but the
Democrats are so dug in on saying know
that I just read that brian schatz the
senator from Hawaii he had left it's 11
hour flight to Hawaii he flew back 11
hours just to vote no so everyone is
quite Duggan you know Greg I know that
your position is you know things happen
right but it's not making it's a lot
making a lot of people and conservative
talk radio the Ann Coulter's the Rush
Limbaugh's right they're like what are
you doing you can't allow the Democrats
to rape what would Greg Gutfeld
advise President Trump to do oh that's a
great question I would say that he's
watching I know no you know what okay
here's when I looked when I listened to
this I find this to be very foolish it
reminds me and I hate to use this the
yani or Laurel thing remember that yeah
so it was blue trumpet has managed to
get Democrats to agree
that having a strong border is important
because when everything getting the
conversation all the Democrats including
you want have said it I want a strong
border everybody say that so he gets
everybody said then he goes okay wall
they go whoo-hoo-hoo not a wall so it's
actually they actually both sides agree
but the Democrats are hung up on
language they are hung up on language
because it's the word it's the word wall
so might I quote somebody mm-hmm Scott
yes Scott Adams why not adjust the
length adjust the language if it's a
wall or if it's a fence who cares call
it a wince right that's a that's a Scott
at its president Trump ones gonna call
it steals lat well oh this is amazing to
me steel slats sounds fantastic to me
that sounds like something pretty cool
you can move it around but you Democrats
will say that this is the wrong way to
cut immigration right because most of
the illegal immigration is overstayed
visas right that's like saying I don't
like a fork because it won't cut my meat
well you have a knife for that so you
have a fork and a knife so you can have
a wall strong border and then you can
then you could address that other stuff
so the arguments are either emotional
flawed or pigheaded when it really
everybody wants the same thing but they
won't give in
so Jedidiah if we do have a shutdown at
midnight you're going to see I think
it's 800,000 federal workers you know 47
of them percent of them will not even
come to work the rest come to work they
won't be paid until the government
reopens their backpack right but then
you have federal contractors out of work
to the the State Department says they'll
keep doing visas restrooms some of the
state federal parks are gonna be closed
what do you think's gonna be the
reaction well I think from the right I
mean people got very nervous when they
thought he wasn't gonna dig his heels in
when he kind of wavered for a second and
they thought oh he said he wouldn't be
afraid to shut the government down now
he is afraid I think he's already done
what he needs to do regardless of how
this works out he's now gonna be the guy
who was willing to go through with the
government shutdown to dig his heels in
and say I'm willing to do that partial
government shutdown
he's also proving that he's willing to
take on the language and say this is a
Democrat shutdown he's taken on the
language when it comes to what a
shutdown actually looks like that it's
not this you know Armageddon
that the left always paints it as that
so many essential government functions
still keep working I just think it's
interesting I watched Chuck Schumer and
he says you're not gonna get your wall
as if the wall is for President Trump
the wall is for the United States of
America it's for our national security
it's to address the humanitarian crisis
at the border
these are we're talking about resources
for Border Patrol agents you just had a
little girl die crossing in horrific
conditions so this idea that he's not
giving him the money despite Trump
you're not spying Trump yours fighting
American citizens and your spy tting all
of those poor people who are being
incentivized to come and cross this
border under these horrific conditions
so I think Democrats should take a
minute and really reflect on that and I
know it sounds good to oppose the wall
but think about what you're actually
opposing which is addressing national
security and the Amana terian credit a
new manatorian crisis that's happening
at the border so alone I think he's
already done what do you have to do so
Jenna die you are so lucky it's like
Santa delivered for you because you got
a Democrat at the table so I would say
to you hey Jedediah I think President
Trump said Mexico is gonna pay for the
wall yeah well and you know I said no a
million times he should have never been
on record saying that because it was
highly unlikely that that was gonna
happen but the bottom line is I mean you
have people opening go fund me accounts
in this country to say you know what if
the government's not gonna do it we're
gonna do it that shouldn't be the case
the primary responsibility of the
government is to protect its citizens
and that includes border security okay
so one final question on this for
everybody so Jesse laid out a potential
endgame a way that the president could
get out of it which is to say look I
really did my best I have tried with
these Democrats I even quit went to the
point I think Jared I have put picked up
on this I'm saying we're going to shut
down a government so will rush limbaugh
the Drudge Report Breitbart well people
like that say you know what mr.
president you did your best
with those doggone Democrat yeah I mean
listen if he goes out out and does
weaken as much as he can and you look at
Mitch McConnell or you look at the House
Republicans and you say you know what
they didn't deliver with the two years
they had majorities but even then you
still need 60 votes
you still need 60 votes you got a new
kid that's what you got to do you got a
nuke option or nothing
thanks Greg when he starts hammering the
table
though you know it is watching
politicians debate over the over the
wall is like watching Dana and I try to
get something down from a high shelf
because there is no expertise right and
I think that was the mistake at the
beginning of this was not introducing
expertise into this problem and said it
started with a price it's like if you or
not if you were gonna go renovate your
house you don't say I'm gonna spend this
now you're gonna figure out what you
want to renovate do I need do I need a
table here do I need a putt and then you
come up with a budget this is I was
gonna say ass-backwards can I say that I
think what we needed and is is like
engineering expertise somebody that says
okay this is what maybe you have a wall
here maybe you don't have a wall here
and then you come up with it but instead
we started from the reverse so that
might be a compromise
well how about our public relations
expert in this Perino what would you
suggest well I don't know how it's gonna
come down but I do think that there was
something that the president and his
administration was able to do yesterday
that got buried it didn't get enough
attention it was actually quite
impressive very impressive secretary of
Department of Homeland Security
Kirsten Nielsen announced that they have
reached this deal with Mexico Lathon
dealer that basically said to Mexico
they're going to a basically house or
hold the asylum seekers so you you are a
migrant you come across you get
processed but then you wait in Mexico
that's a really big deal and the
administration has done lots of
different things that are a part of the
whole cutlery set yes right so there's a
spoon a knife a fork the dessert spoon
everything that they've tried to do all
of that smaller knife there's a lot of
things that they're doing outside of the
wall that could either give them some
cover with their base but also to let
the American people know like they're
not just waiting for five billion
dollars for steel slats or a wall they
actually that's really impressive and
she deserves some credit for that she of
course it got buried because of all the
other breaking sure and also the Supreme
Court had a ruling Jedidiah that said
the administration cannot put a cap on
the number of people seeking asylum it
was an interesting vote because the
Chief Justice John Robert boated with
the Liberals against the administer that
is true as well and I would also say
about the
our value I think it's interesting
there's been a lot of debate about the
five billion dollars people need to
remember he's not just pulling that
number out of thin air I mean he's
talking to Border Patrol agents he's
talking with people at the border and
they're telling him this is what we need
this is what's insufficient so you know
Chuck Schumer doesn't get to his side
what's to decide what's appropriate
amount of money and and frankly neither
does Donald Trump he he is working with
the people on the border so these
numbers exist for a reason because he's
getting it from the people who are there
trying to process people trying to get
them in buses in these remote areas to
other locations trying to make sure that
the proper medical supplies are there
and also trying to contain what's going
on
so that number had there's a reason that
that five billion dollars in terms of a
monetary value even exists
by the way Greg does he go to Myra Largo
if the government shuts there well I'll
talk to him later actually I'm good I'm
hitching a ride with them they serve
drinks on the plane on the sleigh ride